Arthur: I'm Arthur Yap, I'm the Secretary
of Agriculture of the Philippines, and in
2009 I hope that the environment doesn't lose
out.
As secretary of agriculture, if the environment
is not healthy, if there is soil degradation,
if there is no water, if there are no water
sheds then that is the end of agriculture.
And in my country in the Philippines, that's
35% of the labor force, and that's 20% of
the GDP of my country.
So in 2009 I hope that instead of fear, there
will be a mechanism to prod a lot of the polluters
to pay up, and for countries like ours with
a large farm sector to be prodded to do good,
to be rewarded for doing good.
In Davos as in Madrid, I was called in for
new innovative schemes and instruments that
can help fund these efforts.
Because the third world countries, countries
such as the Philippines, it is our people
who are the most vulnerable, who get hit the
most by any impact on the econ -- on the environment
impacts us immediately.
It is our people who are the most vulnerable
and need help the most.
But we must be prodded; we must be [inaudible]
for doing the right thing.
We have the technologies to move into organic
agriculture.
We have the technology to move into better
quality seeds, seeds that don't require as
much water.
We would like to put back our water sheds
and our water resources as well.
So I think the challenge is, how do we get
the world and the private sector cooperating
together and [inaudible] the private sector
and communities to undertake these projects.
So I hope 2009 will not see the year of agricultural
and environmental investments going down.
We must restore a sense of hope, a sense of
courage.
Because despite the recession, and it's impacts
-- I know we are all afraid.
But we have to think of the medium and the
long term.
Just because there is a financial recession
does not mean that problems about the environment
or problems about [inaudible] are going to
go away.
So we must find a way to collaborate, and
we must find a way to create together as a
family, as a member of the family of nations.
Thank you very much.